i don't know i'm still picturing mr b
said at 11. yeah that's good i'm buying
every stripper in here a brand new
birkin bag
if they can make me personal he's evil
mr beast he has to have a different
voice now like a different way of
talking i picture him like the exact
same way but just evil looking just i
don't even know if it
yeah maybe yeah maybe he could have what
were you picturing last week like a
little face tat or something yeah yeah
like he's like no he's got like the uk
yeah yeah
yeah yeah because he has to wear
tracksuit because 11 won't let him in
with all those tats yeah
he's got [ __ ] life on his
on his knuckles and he's four inches
shorter
yeah he's just a little bit smaller but
he's got a huge hog
oh okay i wouldn't know that far
that's why they call him mr beast no
he's got a huge time to find out why
they really call me mr beast or just a
huge hog that he like pulls around on a
chain kind of like a ball like an actual
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah dude somebody has to draw this yeah
please
like a chap yeah like with the best mr
beast with a with a hog on a leash yeah
like a chain leash um
and actually while you're at it like
make his beard wispy like the x-men
like beast
yeah
[Music]
and then mark mark rober is his boy on
the left
yeah
his name is
his name is henry and that's evil mr b's
real name is henry okay
henry we call him beast cause
i don't know bro he just used to file a
time in high school and just with that
[ __ ] crazy beers we just call him mr
beast man what's up with the hog
i don't know
it's just his
it's just his deal yeah him in the club
on the mic i'm gonna buy all this
i'm gonna buy all you [ __ ] birkin
bags
says it just like that that's what i'm
talking about
i'm buying all your but it's gotta start
like a drone shot that pulls back as
he's announcing the title of the video
which is like every single video the way
it started yeah um i'm bi all these
[ __ ] are broken
it's titled 11 days of christmas yeah
and he put two giant christmas trees
in 11.
and he's got the drone shot he's like
what's up guys it's me mr beast i'm
buying all these hoes birkin bags
the drone backs out he's just with the
hog at the dj movie
damn this our beast really went off the
rails and then [ __ ] money went to his
head didn't it yeah then evil mark
rovers on the side just literally doing
meth like he's just hitting a pipe in
11. no he's on the tables okay he's
throwing down like the craziest dj set
you've ever heard
and then smoking meth
between songs or no maybe it's just like
uh
it's like
he has like a [ __ ] meth pipe like
like on a like a paperclip chain yeah
you know this is like a statement yes
and it's just like yeah that's where i
come from and he's just playing like the
craziest like trance yeah house
[Music]
this isn't even a [ __ ] thing like
now i'm just picturing like a sex worker
after a long day just you know dropping
down on the couch and being like what's
mr b step
like
two
like glitter on the face like full
outfit but she's just like
i
just want to relax and they watch mr
beast i mean i'm sure they probably i
mean i'm sure every everyone [ __ ]
does everyone in the world watches mr
beast clearly his squid games video got
over a hundred million views in a week
has it been a week no it's been five
days you released it on wednesday right
yeah oh my god
yeah so this has to be probably the
lamest tweet ever in the world about it
yeah
103 million views in four days it took
seven weeks squid games you know no read
it read it the way like
i was reading it the way it was written
no you said you did you missed the app
mr beast at mr b squid games video 103
million views in four days it took seven
weeks to make at netflix's squid game
series
111 million let's see there it goes
again 11 you just can't escape
111 million views in 30 days it took 10
years to make more views less time fewer
gatekeepers that's the promise of the
creator economy
i really hate
this format that twitter has encouraged
which is just like now it's just mic
drops you know that's everyone wants
that banger tweet where like it's nicely
wrapped up it's like they intro
something and then they just [ __ ] end
it with like a yeah yeah
that's the creator of the prom
roll
that's the creator of the promise
economy yeah
you know or switch the words around but
you get it and then just
mic drop like people get on twitter now
to do homework yeah
yeah like like this is home like you you
have an intro a body paragraph and a
conclusion yes [ __ ] story exactly
here so you're writing a full essay here
yeah twitter in my mind is like where
you're supposed to like think out loud
say [ __ ] that's like stupid it's it's
that's how you stimulate the
conversation yeah you'll [ __ ] come in
there with an email and yeah
you know i've been doing a lot of
thinking about this but i wasn't trying
to oh [ __ ] shut up a thread [ __ ] oh what
and then it's actually it actually is an
essay a lot of the times yeah
that's why tweets had limited characters
because there's a point yeah where
you're supposed to shut the [ __ ] up yeah
after 250 letters we don't care yeah
i'm i know this you know after 500
letters of me talking on this podcast
everyone's like
all right noelle like i can you know i
know this i can speak from experience no
but seriously the thing about perverse
family
so mr b should recreate perverse family
and see
how many views he gets
i'm giving everyone in this town
10 million dollars to eat all this poop
oh my god
anyway this tweet like i found a pretty
funny it's like a top tweet but like
seven weeks to remove all cultural
significance and impact remove all
storytelling weight and aspect and
essentially cannibalize the work of
someone with actual creativity oh damn
then you put in bold creator economy
i mean that's perfect
that sums up youtube to the fullest yeah
that's here's why that's perfect
a thread
okay
everyone just oh my god
turned off the
[ __ ] no but the best part about this
too is that like it's saying like
netflix's squid games took this long to
make
and and this long to hit a hundred
million views or whatever and then mr mr
beast's remix
mr bezos mr no mr based
mr [ __ ] mr bass
mr best
ruffles based anyway but he just ripped
it off that's the thing yeah
this is no shade man no no shade at all
it's like it's still massively
impressive to make anything that hits
100 million views in four days that
could be the most impressive thing ever
in content honestly yeah like the scale
at which he did this yeah
was so impressive like the fact that
every set was just as big
and just as grand as the real thing and
he did that in yeah seven weeks like
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah you know cost
millions just like we it's just like we
had uh
thought yeah yeah
you